This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. One of the most famous comedy sketches of the 20th century is built on a simple misunderstanding. With this pretend that we're organizing a baseball team here at the retired actors' home, and I am the manager. It's the routine from Abbott and Costello, who's on first? Well, let's see now, we have on our team we have who's on first, what's on second, I don't know, who's on third.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。20世纪最著名的喜剧小品之一，就建立在一个简单的误解之上。假设我们在退休演员之家组织一个棒球队，我是经理。这是阿博特和科斯特洛的常规表演，谁在一垒？好吧，让我们看看，我们队里有一垒手“谁”，二垒手“什么”，我不知道，三垒手是谁。
That's what I want to find out. That's the guy's name. That's what I want to find out, the guy's name. I'm telling you, who's on first, what's on second, I don't know, who's on third. That's what I want to find out. That's what I want to find out. I'm telling you who's on first, what's on second, I don't know, who's on third. The duo first performed the sketch in the 1930s and continued to refine it over the next two decades. They rarely did it the same way twice. You know what it does, names had a baseball face. Who's on first? Yes. I mean the guys name.
这就是我想知道的。那是那个家伙的名字。这就是我想知道的，那个家伙的名字。我告诉你，一垒是谁，二垒是什么，我不知道，三垒是谁。这就是我想知道的。这就是我想知道的。我告诉你，一垒是谁，二垒是什么，我不知道，三垒是谁。这对二人组在20世纪30年代首次表演了这个小品，并在接下来的二十年里不断完善它。他们很少用同样的方式表演两次。你知道它是怎么回事吗，名字听起来像棒球运动员。谁在一垒？是的。我是指那个家伙的名字。
Who? They got play first. Who? They got play first. Who? They got play first. Who is on first? Yes. I mean the guys name. Who? They got play first. Who? They got play first. Who is on first? Why do you ask me for? I don't know. Part of what makes the skit funny is that we are in on the joke.
谁？他们得守一垒。谁？他们得守一垒。谁？他们得守一垒。谁在一垒？是的。我是指那个家伙的名字。谁？他们得守一垒。谁？他们得守一垒。谁在一垒？你为什么问我？我不知道。这个小品好笑的部分原因在于我们都懂这个梗。
But what happens when the jokes on us? When real life conversations go off the rails because of miscommunication or a misunderstanding, it's no laughing matter. There are so many things that could misfire the pace at which you speak, how you get to the point, the rhythms, the intonation patterns, humor. That is a minefield. How do you let people know that you're joking and that you're teasing?
但是，当笑话落到我们头上时会发生什么呢？当现实生活中的对话因为沟通不畅或误解而脱轨时，这就不是闹着玩的了。有很多事情可能会出岔子：你说话的节奏、你切入正题的方式、韵律、语调模式、幽默。那简直是个雷区。你怎么让别人知道你在开玩笑、你在逗趣？
This week on Hidden Brain, how the unthinking patterns in the way we express ourselves can cause unneeded pain and conflict, and how we can learn to talk and listen better. You say tomato, I say tomato. If you travel abroad, you instinctively know that the customs in other countries are different. People have different ways of saying hello and goodbye. Different rules for conversations with friends. In recent decades, the linguist Deborah Tannen has discovered that many of us don't need to travel to exotic lands to experience the bewilderment and confusion of cross-cultural communication. We can experience those very same feelings when we talk to our own siblings, parents, partners, children, friends, and colleagues. She studies why this happens and how we can all have better conversations with the people in
本周的《隐藏大脑》，我们将探讨我们表达自己时那些不经意的模式如何导致不必要的痛苦和冲突，以及我们如何学会更好地交谈和倾听。你说番茄（tomato），我说番茄（tomahto）。如果你去国外旅行，你本能地知道其他国家的习俗是不同的。人们有不同的问候和道别方式。与朋友对话时有不同的规则。在过去的几十年里，语言学家黛博拉·泰伦发现，我们许多人不需要去异国他乡，就能体验到跨文化交流带来的迷惑和困惑。当我们与自己的兄弟姐妹、父母、伴侣、孩子、朋友和同事交谈时，我们就会体验到完全相同的感觉。她研究为什么会发生这种情况，以及我们如何才能与生活中
our lives. Deborah Tannen, welcome to Hidden Brain. Such a pleasure to be here. Thank you. You were born in Brooklyn, New York. Your parents were immigrants, one from Poland, one from Russia. They were both very alert to the ways people use language, but also alert to subtleties in human relationships. Can you tell me a little bit about the conversations you had at home and also the conversations you sometimes had about those conversations. Yes, both told stories about people and also how people, things people had said and how people used language. My father, in particular, was really attuned to
的人进行更好的对话。黛博拉·泰伦，欢迎来到《隐藏大脑》。非常高兴来到这里。谢谢你。你出生在纽约布鲁克林。你的父母是移民，一个来自波兰，一个来自俄罗斯。他们对人们使用语言的方式非常敏感，同时也对人际关系的微妙之处保持敏锐。你能跟我谈谈你在家里进行的对话，以及你有时对这些对话进行的讨论吗？是的，两人都讲过关于人的故事，也讲过人们、别人说过的话以及人们如何使用语言。特别是我的父亲，对
subtleties of language. And I remember one time he was telling me about an ant that he had particularly liked. And he said, now there was this expression, chas fachalila, something like heaven forbid. And he said, but she said chalila vajas. And he said, I remember it because nobody else said it that way. So he had that attunement to subtleties of language. And my mother was very interested in relationships. She was an electrolyteist,
语言的微妙之处非常敏锐。我记得有一次他跟我讲起他特别喜欢的一只蚂蚁。他说，当时有一个词组，chas fachalila，有点像“天哪”或“上帝保佑”。他说，但她说的是chalila vajas。他说，我记得这件事是因为没有其他人那样说。所以他对语言的微妙之处有着那样的敏感。而我的母亲对人际关系非常感兴趣。她是一名电解脱毛师，
it's a removal of unwanted hair. And she would always be telling us about the stories her patients had told her that day. And so that combination of attunement to language and true relationships kind of came together for me. So years later, you grew up, you got married, your husband was Greek and you were living in Greece.
也就是通过电解去除不想要的毛发。她总是给我们讲她的病人们那天跟她讲的故事。所以，这种对语言的敏感和对真实关系的关注对我来说就融合在了一起。所以多年以后，你长大了，你结婚了，你的丈夫是希腊人，你住在希腊。
You've written that your conversation styles were very different, especially when it came to being direct with one another. Can you give me an example or two of how this worked, Deborah? Yes, I would ask him a question, John's having a party and you want to go. And he would say something like, okay, now to me, okay, is not an answer, I want to go, I don't want to go. So I would say, are you sure you want to go? And he would say, why don't you make up your mind? No, where did that come from? And this is one that I actually went on and tested. And sure enough, the Greeks that I interviewed
你曾写道，你们的对话风格非常不同，特别是在彼此坦诚直率方面。黛博拉，你能给我举一两个例子说明这是怎么运作的吗？是的，我会问他一个问题：“约翰要举办一个派对，你想去吗？”他会说类似“好的”这样的话。对当时的我和我来说，“好的”并不是一个回答，我想去或者我不想去。所以我可能会说：“你确定你想去吗？”他会说：“你怎么就不能拿定主意呢？”不，这又是从何说起呢？这也是我后来亲自去测试过的一个例子。果不其然，我采访并
and gave them this example were most likely to say the wife wouldn't ask unless she wanted to go and she wouldn't double check unless she wasn't happy with the decision. Deborah was intrigued by the many ways people understood and misunderstood each other. Eventually, she returned to the United States and began a PhD in linguistics. One Thanksgiving, she decided to do some research by recording a conversation
向他们给出这个例子的希腊人最倾向于认为：如果妻子不是想去，她就不会问；如果她对这个决定不满意，她就不会反复确认。黛博拉对人们相互理解和误解的种种方式很感兴趣。最终，她回到了美国，并开始攻读语言学博士学位。有一年感恩节，她决定通过录下一段与朋友的对话来进行一些研究
with friends. I wonder how our grandparents dealt with our Thanksgiving. Two were from California, one was from the UK, Debra and two others were New Yorkers. It was simply my best friend, his brother, his former wife, and two of his friends who were in town. Remember with WI and S2's to be? No. They both the big, huge, sky fair for that? No.
我不知道我们的祖父母是如何应对我们的感恩节的。其中两人来自加利福尼亚，一人来自英国，黛布拉和其他两人是纽约人。那只是我最好的朋友、他的兄弟、他的前妻以及当时在城的另外两个朋友。还记得有WI和S2吗？没有。他们两个为此举办了盛大的集市吗？没有。
Where was that? We're at the Central Park Westman for a while. Did they give you a picture? That's all on the circle. Here's all on the circle circuit? Is that the long circuit? Here's the long circuit. Now it's the long circuit. That's the long circuit, right? I don't know. And what I found, first of all, was that I could not
那是在哪里？我们在中央公园西侧待了一会儿。他们给你照片了吗？那全在那个圈子里吗？这全在环形线路上吗？那是长路线吗？这是长路线。现在是长路线。那是长路线，对吧？我不知道。而我发现，首先，我无法
study the conversational styles of each of the people who was there because it was difficult for the Californians to get the floor. He's a sociologist who's so brilliant. You have to read. And it goes. Where's your reading? Which one is PEPP?
研究在场每个人的对话风格，因为加州人很难插话。他是一位如此才华横溢的社会学家。你必须读读。然后开始了。你的阅读在哪里？哪一个是PEPP？
A silence? All of them. And I had to conclude that I was getting a chance to observe the conversational styles of the three New Yorkers, but not of the others, because they were not able to exercise their natural conversational style. It's not that they never spoke,
一段沉默？所有人都是。我不得不得出结论，我只是有机会观察到三个纽约人的对话风格，而没有观察到其他人的，因为他们无法展现自己自然的对话风格。并不是说他们从不说话，
but they couldn't be part of the back and forth given take because anytime anyone talks to anyone, we need a sense of how long a pause we think is normal between turns. And the New Yorker's sense of how long a pause was normal was shorter. And so while the Californians and even more the British women, while they
而是他们无法参与到那种你来我往的互动中，因为每当任何人与任何人交谈时，我们需要对轮流发言之间我们认为多长的停顿是正常的有一个感知。而纽约人对多长的停顿才算正常的感知更短。因此，当加州人，尤其是英国女性，还在
were just waiting for a normal pause so that they could come in, one of the New Yorkers would get the sense, oh, you know, they have nothing to say. We might as well fill this pause. What's the analyze? There hasn't been one misunderstanding. We've all understood each other perfectly. What do you mean by that? I want to pause for a moment and just look at what you actually did as you were analyzing
等待一个正常的停顿以便她们能够插话时，其中一个纽约人就会觉得，哦，你知道的，他们没什么好说的。我们不妨填补这个空白。分析什么？甚至没有发生过误解。我们彼此完全理解。你这话是什么意思？我想暂停一会儿，来看看你在分析对话时实际做了什么，
the conversation, because once you had this recording in hand, it took you two and a half months to transcribe this three hour conversation, how much detail were you trying to capture? I wanted to capture everything that I was aware of that I had perceived. So I made notes in the transcription whether a person said the or the, but I had a stopwatch and measured the number of seconds between words when it was a perceptible pause. And I had it checked by the people who had been part of the conversation, they listened to it and checked it for me.
因为一旦你手头有了这段录音，你花了两个半月的时间来转录这段长达三小时的对话，你当时试图捕捉多少细节呢？我想捕捉我所意识到并感知到的一切。所以我在转录中做了笔记，记录一个人说的是“the”（弱读）还是“the”（强读），我有一个秒表，当出现明显的停顿时刻，我测量了词与词之间的秒数。我还让参与对话的人进行了核对，他们听了录音并帮我进行了核对。
What I find really insightful and remarkable here is that it actually took that level of care and precision and detail for you to actually realize that there was something happening beneath the surface of the conversation, the way people said certain things. What was the insight that you took away Debra about the ways in which conversational styles affected how conversations unfolded and how people perceived one another? Well, one of the insights is that you have to look more deeply to see what the intentions were and how the way one person speaks is actually influenced by how another person speaks. Some people might have concluded the New Yorkers are interrupting because they're
我在这里发现的真正深刻且引人注目的是，你实际上付出了那种程度的细心、精确和细节，才真正意识到在对话表面之下正在发生某些事情，即人们说特定方式的话的方式。黛博拉，你从中得出的关于对话风格如何影响对话展开以及人们如何看待彼此的见解是什么？嗯，其中一个见解是，你必须更深入地观察，才能看出意图是什么，以及一个人说话的方式实际上是如何受到另一个人说话方式影响的。有些人可能会得出结论，认为纽约人打断别人是因为他们
starting to talk when someone else is speaking. Well, sometimes we talk along as a way of showing enthusiasm. We're so interested. We don't wait for you to stop. We talk along. That was it. I should have had it. I should have had it. You should have had it.
在别人说话时开始抢话。嗯，有时我们一同说话是为了表达热情。我们太感兴趣了。我们不会等你停下。我们一起说。就是这样。我本该拿着的。我本该拿着的。你本该拿着的。
Yeah, we did together. That's right. We did together. I was like, I was like, I was like, I was like, I was like, I should have had it. We should have had it. We should have had it. We should have had it.
是的，我们一起做的。没错。我们一起做的。我当时就像是，我当时就像是，我当时就像是，我当时就像是，我当时就像是，我本该拿着的。我们本该拿着的。我们本该拿着的。我们本该拿着的。
We should have had it. We should have had it. We should have had it. And, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, and I'll stop. Well, who created that interruption? It took two people, someone to start and someone to stop. Another aspect of the style of the New Yorkers. It isn't the job of a speaker to make sure that other people get the floor. You might say it's a sign of respect. You trust other people to get the floor if they want. And so if someone tried to bring up a topic and others were speaking and they didn't stop for them, they would try again. And if it still wasn't picked up, they would try again. Should we do that? Should we start with the word about the lady who was asked?
我们本该拿着的。我们本该拿着的。我们本该拿着的。而且，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我们本该，我就此打住。好吧，是谁造成了那种打断？这需要两个人，一个开始，另一个停下。纽约人说话风格的另一个方面。确保其他人有发言机会并不是说话者的工作。你可能会说这是一种尊重的表现。你相信如果其他人想发言，他们自己会争取到发言机会。因此，如果有人试图挑起一个话题而其他人正在说话，并且他们没有为他停下来，他就会再试一次。如果还是没人接话，他会再试一次。我们该这么做吗？我们要从关于那个被问及的女士的话题开始吗？
Okay. Did he hear? We have said board girl board. Board girl board. Who had the lady who was asked? What? Did he hear about the lady who was asked? And there was one example where one of the New Yorkers, it wasn't he, tried seven times
好的。他听到了吗？我们说过board girl board。Board girl board。谁有那个被问及的女士？什么？他听到关于那个被问及的女士的事了吗？其中有一个例子，其中一个纽约人——不是他本人——尝试了七次，
before he got his turn to say what he wanted to say. The Californians wouldn't do that. If they tried to say something and it wasn't picked up, they gave up. Did you notice things about your own conversational style in that recording because for the first time probably you were actually slowing down and listening to yourself speak? Yes, yes. I did. And in some cases was kind of embarrassed when I saw the effect of my ways of speaking. An example of that is what I ended up calling machine gun questions. So I was talking to my friend Carl, he's my best friend, but one of the guests was a friend of his who was visiting from Los Angeles.
才终于轮到他说出他想说的话。加州人可不会那样。如果他们试图说点什么而没人接话，他们就放弃了。你在那段录音中注意到自己对话风格的一些特点了吗？因为这可能是你第一次真正放慢速度，听自己说话？是的，是的。我注意到了。在某些情况下，当我看到自己说话方式产生的影响时，甚至感到有点尴尬。这其中的一个例子就是我最终称之为“机关枪式提问”的现象。当时我正在和我朋友卡尔说话，他是我最好的朋友，但其中一位客人是从洛杉矶来访的朋友的朋友。
The name was Chuck. So I was trying to be friendly to Chuck and make him feel, welcome here. So the truth as I knew the answers to these questions, because Carl had told me, but I was trying to be nice to Chuck and give him the floor. And the conversation went something like this. I said, you're from LA? You live in LA? Yeah. You're visiting here?
名字叫查克。所以我当时试图对查克表现得友好，让他觉得在这里受到欢迎。事实上，我知道这些问题的答案，因为卡尔已经告诉我了，但我试图对查克好一点，把发言权交给他。对话大致是这样的。我说：“你是从洛杉矶来的？你住在洛杉矶吗？是的。你是来这里旅游的？
What do you do there? What do you do there? I work at Disney Museum. You're a writer? Artists? Yeah. Yeah. All right.
你在那里做什么？你在那里做什么？我在迪士尼博物馆工作。你是作家？艺术家？是的。是的。好吧。
I'm advertising copy. Yeah, all right. Every time I think I'll be. I think it was one after another and this high pitch, Clip-Sintax, and when I listened to the tape, I realized it was having the opposite effect of what I expected. He wasn't taking the floor and he wasn't talking. And I talked to him about it afterwards. I'm still in touch with all these people who were there. He was just caught off guard by the rapidity of my questions. So was that to a permanent full-time thing you had?
我是广告文案。是的，好吧。每当我以为我……我想这是一个接一个，高音调、快语速。当我听录音时，我意识到这起到了与我预期相反的效果。他没有接话，也没有说话。事后我和他谈过这件事。我和所有这些在场的人都还保持着联系。他只是被我问题的密集度弄得措手不及。所以那是你做的一项永久性的全职工作吗？
So you eat? Yeah. It seemed like he was being assaulted by machine gun fire. And instead of backing off, did you go there for that purpose? And downshifting. I was putting on more and more of these questions. Had you go there for that purpose? And downshifting. I was putting on more and more of these questions. Did you get that job? Oh, the dads were first in 1937. Right. So the
所以你吃吗？是的。看起来他好像遭到了机关枪火力的袭击。你不仅没有退缩，反而为了那个目的而去了吗？并且转换低速档。我抛出了越来越多的这种问题。你为了那个目的去那里的吗？并且转换低速档。我抛出了越来越多的这种问题。你得到那份工作了吗？哦，阿博特和科斯特洛的电影是在1937年上映的。没错。所以，
interesting thing there is that if you share a conversational style with someone, you essentially can play this game where in other words, you can interrupt the flow of a conversation with sort of very quick machine gun exchanges and neither party thinks of it as being obnoxious or rude. But if you don't share the same conversational styles, then the very same interruption can come across as being completely different and clearly over the Thanksgiving dinner, some of that was happening. Absolutely. And by the way, these mutual and negative impressions go both ways.
有趣的是，如果你和某人分享一种对话风格，你基本上可以玩这个游戏，换句话说，你可以用非常快速的机关枪式的交流来打断对话的流畅度，双方都不会觉得这很讨厌或粗鲁。但是，如果你没有相同的对话风格，那么同样的打断就会显得完全不同，很明显，在感恩节晚餐上，有些这样的情况正在发生。绝对是这样。顺便说一句，这些相互的负面印象是双向的。
It isn't only the ones who are talking along to show enthusiasm run the risk of being seen as rude, but people who sit there and don't do their part in the conversation that also comes across as rude. And this is really a universal about human relations and about conversational style. If you talk to someone who shares a conversational style with you, you just talk in a way that to you make sense a conversational style with you, you just talk in a way that you make sense, it makes sense to them. And it isn't only that they don't think you're rude. It's that they appreciate the way you are appreciating them. It is like a sign of, we get each other.
不仅是那些为了表现热情而插话的人有被视为粗鲁的风险，那些坐在那里却不在对话中尽本分的人也会给人留下粗鲁的印象。这确实是关于人际关系和对话风格的一个普遍现象。如果你和一个与你有相同对话风格的人交谈，你说话的方式对你来说是有意义的，对他们来说也是有意义的。不仅他们不觉得你粗鲁，而且他们会欣赏你对他们的欣赏。这就像是一个信号，表明：我们懂彼此。
This is a great conversation. A perfectly tuned conversation is the vision of sanity. A reassurance that you are a right sort of person and all is right with the world. Debra realized that underneath the conversations we think we are having, there are other conversations unfolding beneath the surface. Lots of us are not aware of these hidden conversations. These things are so automatic that when things start to go wrong, we don't look at that level. You don't walk away saying, you know, that was kind of awkward because I think you expect a millisecond short of pause than I do.
这是一场极好的对话。一场完美契合的对话是理智的愿景。它是一种保证，让你确信你是一个正直的人，世界一切安好。黛博拉意识到，在我们以为自己正在进行的对话之下，还有其他对话在水面之下展开。我们很多人并没有意识到这些隐藏的对话。这些事情是如此的自动化，以至于当事情开始出错时，我们不会去那个层面寻找原因。你不会走开并说：“你知道，刚才有点尴尬，因为我认为你期望的停顿时间比我短几毫秒。”
You walk away saying the kind of person you are. You didn't want to give me a chance to talk or you only want to hear yourself talk or the other side. Why do I have, is the conversation with you like pulling teeth? You write at one point what makes misunderstandings resulting from conversational style differences so hard to clear up is that we don't have a way of talking about them. We don't think of saying when my voice has that quality, it means I'm being friendly. Such cues are sent and perceived automatically.
你会走开并说：“你就是那种人。你不想给我说话的机会，或者你只想听你自己说话，”或者反过来。为什么我——和你对话简直就像拔牙一样？你在某个地方写道，由对话风格差异导致的误解之所以很难澄清，是因为我们没有谈论它们的方式。我们不会去想说：“当我的声音有那种特质时，意思是我是友善的。”这种信号是自动发出和被感知的。
And I might add, they're probably sent and perceived unconsciously. If you and I are not using the same code book about what a pause means, what a certain tone means, we might constantly misunderstand one another, even though both of us have the best of intentions. Yes, and astonishingly, I mean, this even happens among people who are married to each other, lived together or know each other very well. So here's another example of lifelong friends. I think at this point they're in their 80s,
我要补充的是，它们可能是无意识地发出和被感知的。如果你和我对于“停顿意味着什么”、“某种语气意味着什么”没有使用相同的密码本，我们可能会不断地误解彼此，即使我们双方都怀揣着最好的意愿。是的，令人惊讶的是，我的意思是，这甚至发生在彼此结婚、同居或非常了解对方的人身上。这里还有一个一生朋友的例子。我想这个时候他们已经80多岁了，
and they've been friends since they were teens. They were walking along around a lake, and one was telling about something that was she was concerned about. And then there's a duck coming along the lake with her little ducklings behind her. And the one who notices it, oh, look at that duck,
而且他们从十几岁起就是朋友了。他们正在湖边散步，其中一个人在讲述一件她关心的事。然后一只母鸭带着她的小鸭子顺着湖面游了过来，注意到这一幕的那个人说：“哦，看那只鸭子，
isn't that charming? And her friend said, you're not listening to me. And she said, of course, I'm listening to you. Why would you think, I'm not listening to you? Well, why are you talking about the ducks? Oh. Oh. When we come back, how these misunderstandings produce deep wounds in relationships and keep
多迷人啊？”她的朋友说：“你根本没在听我说话。”她说：“我当然在听你说话。你为什么会觉得我没在听你说话呢？”“那为什么你要谈论鸭子呢？”哦。哦。广告之后，我们将探讨这些误解如何在人际关系中造成深深的伤痕，并阻碍人们获得
people from the happiness that is actually within their reach. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Debra Tanen is a linguist at Georgetown University. She is the author of nearly a dozen books about how people talk to one another and the ways in which misunderstandings arise in conversation. Early in her career, she discovered that many of these misunderstandings were unintentional. I think you're saying something that you're not saying, because without being aware of it,
其实触手可及的幸福。欢迎收听《隐藏大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。黛博拉·泰伦是乔治城大学的语言学家。她著有近十本书，探讨人们如何相互交谈以及对话中如何产生误解。在职业生涯的早期，她发现许多此类误解都是非故意的。我认为你在表达一些你实际上并未表达的意思，因为在不知不觉中，
we have different styles of conversation or different psychological orientations. Deborah, lots of academics get their work presented at conferences, some of them write books, you've done those things, but you also had a TV show inspired by your ideas. For our younger or overseas listeners who are not familiar with this show, can you tell us the premise of home improvement? Yes, home improvement was a situation comedy,
我们有着不同的对话风格或不同的心理取向。黛博拉，许多学者的研究成果都在会议上发表过，其中一些人写过书，你做过这些，但你还有一个受你的想法启发的电视节目。对于不熟悉这个节目的我们较年轻的听众或海外听众，你能告诉我们《家居装修》（Home Improvement）这部剧的设定吗？是的，《家居装修》是一部情景喜剧，
a man who's kind of a handyman type and he's got a relationship with his wife, and then whenever they have arguments, which they have often, the premise of the individual segments is some argument they have, he would go out in the backyard and talk over the fence to his neighbor, and the neighbor would shed light on these arguments and it was actually told to me by the people who produced and created the show. The neighbor's advice came out of my books. Tim, Tim, Tim, the first step for greatness is humbling yourself. Maybe you shouldn't
一个有点像杂务工类型的男人，他和妻子有着某种关系，每当他们发生争吵时——他们经常争吵——每个片段的前提都是他们发生的某种争吵，他会走到后院，隔着篱笆和邻居说话，而邻居会为这些争吵提供一些启发，实际上制作和创作这部剧的人告诉我，邻居的建议正是出自我的书。蒂姆，蒂姆，蒂姆，迈向伟大的第一步是保持谦逊。也许你不应该
try to have all the answers and instead ask more questions. You see Tim, a truly wise man always has more questions than answers. Deborah, I want to play you another clip from Home Improvement. Jill, who's the wife, has prepared a surprise romantic dinner. She gets on the phone and asks Tim to come home. He says he'll be back in 15 minutes. But he ends up staying the whole evening at a bar with his friends. Here's what happens when he comes home. I'm really sorry, but the guy's not gotten some real serious discussions about relationship things, you know.
试图拥有所有答案，而是提出更多问题。你看，蒂姆，一个真正聪明的人总是问题多于答案。黛博拉，我想给你放另一段《家居装修》的片段。作为妻子的吉尔准备了一场惊喜的浪漫晚餐。她打电话让蒂姆回家。他说他15分钟内回来。但他最终和朋友在酒吧待了整整一晚。当他回家时发生了这样的事情。我真的很抱歉，但这家伙和我有了一些关于关系问题的严肃讨论，你知道的。
Men, women's stuff, sharing feelings. Pretty heavy stuff. feelings. Pretty heavy stuff. I spent two days planning this evening. Do you have any idea how long it's been since we had a quiet, romantic evening together? I was on the phone once you said, come home. I wanted to surprise you. Good night. Come on, Jill. I don't go out with these guys every night. What's making you so angry?
男人和女人的事情，分享感受。挺沉重的话题。感受。挺沉重的话题。我花了两天时间策划今晚。你知道我们有多久没有过一个安静、浪漫的二人世界了吗？我一接电话你就说，回家。我想给你个惊喜。晚安。得了吧，吉尔。我又不是每天晚上都跟这帮家伙出去。是什么让你这么生气？
I am angry because you said you're going to be home in 15 minutes and then you worked. Because I'm flirting with you like crazy on the phone. You didn't even notice. And most of all, because I went to all this trouble for nothing. I spent the whole evening by myself and now you're stuck with a plate of cold food. Don't worry about me. I ain't at the bar.
我很生气，因为你说你15分钟内回家，然后你却……因为我在电话里疯狂地对你调情。你甚至都没注意到。最重要的是，因为我白白费了这么多功夫。我一个人过了整整一晚，现在你得面对一盘冷掉的食物。别担心我。我才不在酒吧吃。
So unpack what just happened here, Deborah. I think the trouble could be traced to the conversation where she feels that she communicated in her way of speaking to him that she was flirting, that she was trying to set up a romantic atmosphere, and then didn't tell him directly, come home, I have a surprise for you, or it's really important, you come home tonight, he said it'll be home in 15 minutes, fine, she took a surprise for you or it's really important you come home tonight.
黛博拉，那么请剖析一下刚刚发生了什么。我认为麻烦可以追溯到那通电话，她觉得她通过自己的说话方式向他传达了她在调情，她试图营造一个浪漫的氛围，然后却没有直接告诉他“回家，我为你准备了惊喜”或者“这真的很重要，你今晚回家”，他说他15分钟内回家，好吧，她把字面意思当真了。她没有说“我为你准备了惊喜，这真的很重要，你今晚必须回家”。
He said it'll be home in 15 minutes. Fine. She took a matter's word. And this is such a common cultural difference between women and men. If you think of women's and men's ways of speaking as cultural differences, he expected that his wife would just tell him directly. And so his antenna were not rolled out for picking up those hints.
他说他15分钟内回家。好吧。她相信了他的话。这真是女性和男性之间非常普遍的文化差异。如果你把女性和男性的说话方式视为文化差异，他预期他的妻子会直接告诉他。因此，他的天线并没有伸出来去捕捉那些暗示。
And he feels falsely accused. You didn't tell me there was a special reason for me to come home. So how could I know? What do you expect me to be a mind reader? Yeah. And we talked about this earlier as well, sort of the difference between people
他觉得自己被诬陷了。你又没告诉我有什么特殊原因非得让我回家不可。那我怎么会知道？你难道指望我是个读心术士吗？是的。我们之前也讨论过这一点，也就是喜欢直话直说的人和倾向于使用更多暗示性、委婉言辞的人之间的区别。你有一个叫做“生日礼物常规”的概念阐述了这个观点。这是什么？
who prefer their speech to be direct and people who prefer to use more indirect speech. You have something called the birthday present routine that illustrates this idea. What is it? People who tend to be direct don't understand why anyone would be indirect, but sometimes they can understand it if you think of the birthday present routine. You want the person you love and who loves you to give you a birthday present that you would want because it's a sign that they care, that they are willing to take the trouble to figure out what to get you, that they know you well enough to pick the right thing. Now you could say, well why don't you just tell them what you want?
倾向于直来直去的人不明白为什么有人会拐弯抹角，但有时如果你想想“生日礼物常规”，你就能理解了。你希望你爱的人以及爱你的人送你一份你想要的生日礼物，因为这是一个信号，表明他们在乎你，他们愿意花心思去弄清楚该给你买什么，他们足够了解你，能挑出正确的东西。现在你可能会说：“好吧，那你为什么不直接告诉他们你想要什么呢？”
That would guarantee that you get what you want. You might get what you want, but you don't get all those other things that you want. Evidence that they care, evidence that they know you well enough to know what you would want. And so that is how indirectness works in other contexts as well. And I think it's so important to point out, first of all, it's not always women and men. And in the conversations with my husband, I was the one who was more likely to be direct.
那确实能保证你得到你想要的东西。你可能会得到你想要的，但你得不到所有其他你想要的东西。那是他们关心你的证据，是他们足够了解你从而知道你会想要什么东西的证据。这就是委婉在其他语境下运作的方式。我认为非常重要的一点是要指出，首先，这并不总是关于女性和男性。在我与丈夫的对话中，我反而是那个更倾向于直来直去的人。
He was the one more likely to be indirect. So there's a lot of cultural differences, regional differences, ethnic differences, all kinds of other influences. The way we say what we mean seems so obviously the way to do it, that you really have to learn to step back and say, could this person that I love be using a different style? We think that because we speak the same language and we think because we love each other or we like each other or we're relatives. We should understand each other.
他反而是那个更有可能委婉表达的人。所以这其中有很多文化差异、地域差异、族裔差异以及各种其他影响。我们表达真意的方式看起来是那么理所当然的做法，以至于你真的必须学会退一步问一句：我爱的这个人会不会是在使用一种不同的风格呢？我们认为，因为我们说同一种语言，因为我们彼此相爱或互相喜欢，或者我们是亲戚，
When misunderstandings arise in closed relationships as a result of these underlying differences in communication styles, it can sometimes send a big message to both parties. This relationship isn't working. Deborah mentions a real-life example she heard of a couple driving in a car. And she had said to him, are you thirsty, dear? Would you like to stop for a drink? And he wasn't, so he said no. And then later it turned out that she was annoyed because she had wanted to stop. And his feeling, kind of like the home-improving example, was, why didn't she tell me, why does she play games with me?
我们就应该互相理解。当亲密关系中由于这些潜在的沟通风格差异而产生误解时，有时会向双方传递一个强烈的信号：这段关系出问题了。黛博拉提到了她听说过的一个真实例子，一对夫妇开车出行。她对他说：“亲爱的，你渴吗？你想停下来喝一杯吗？”他不渴，所以他说不。后来事实证明她很恼火，因为她其实想停下来。而他的感觉——有点像《家居装修》里的例子——是：为什么她不直接告诉我？为什么她要跟我玩心理游戏？
Why do I have to be a mind reader? And I said, you know, I suspect that when your wife said, are you thirsty, would you like to stop for a drink? She probably was not expecting a yes, no answer. She probably expected something like, I don't know, how do you feel about it? Yeah. And then she could say, I don't know, how do you feel about it? And then she could say, I don't know. How do you feel about it?
为什么非要让我当个读心术士？我说：“你知道的，我猜当你的妻子说‘你渴吗？你想停下来喝一杯吗？’时，她可能并没有期望得到一个‘是’或‘否’的回答。她可能期望得到类似‘我不知道，你觉得呢？’这样的回应。”是的。然后她就可以说“我不知道，你觉得呢？”然后她可以说“我不知道。你觉得呢？”
She was communicating that she didn't want to make a demand. She want to know how it would be with him. Now, why would she think she has to do that and why would he not think so? My guess is that his style says you can just throw out my deal. And if I don't like it, I'll tell you. So you start specific and you work your way out. Other people, and she seems to be one who does it this way, you start vague and work your way in. You cite the anthropologist Gregory Bateson, who talks about something called the message
她是在传达这样一个信息：她不想提出强硬的要求。她想知道他的感受如何。现在，为什么她会觉得她必须这样做，而他却不这么认为呢？我猜他的风格是：你可以直接抛出我的想法。如果我不喜欢，我会告诉你。所以你是从具体的点开始，然后逐步推开。而其他人——她似乎就是这种人——你是从模糊的起点开始，然后逐步深入。你引用了人类学家格雷戈里·贝特森（Gregory Bateson）的观点，他谈到了
and the meta-message. Can you explain those terms to me? Yes. The message is the meaning of the words. The meta-message is what it says about the relationship that you say these words in this way, in this context. Often we end up arguing about the message when it's the meta-message that upset us. I was walking with a colleague of mine, woman on college campus, and one of our older male colleagues,
还有元信息。你能向我解释一下这些术语吗？可以。信息是字面本身的含义。元信息则是你以这种方式、在这样的语境下说出这些话时，它所反映出的你们之间的关系。通常，我们最终会为信息争论不休，但真正让我们心烦意乱的往往是元信息。有一次我和我的一个女同事走在大学校园里，碰到了我们的一位年长男同事，
Kostya Peth, and it was one of these brisk fall days in the Northeast, and she said to him, hi, where's your coat? And he said, thanks mom. And then as he walked away, she kind of said, what was that about? What was the metamessage of her asking, where's your coat? For her was a metamessage of friendliness. And if you say something about a person's welfare, that shows another level of caring about them.
科斯塔·佩斯。那是东北部一个清爽的秋日，她对他说：“嗨，你的外套呢？”他说：“谢谢妈妈。”然后等他走开后，她有点纳闷地说：“那是怎么回事？”她问“你的外套呢”，其元信息是什么？对她而言，这传递的是友好的元信息。如果你对一个人的健康状况说点什么，这表现出了一种关怀的层次。
He responded to the meta message that this is a way of mother talks to a child, or a person in a position of authority talks just a subordinate. It points up another dynamic that often comes up with women and men who again can come up between any two people. Anytime we talk to each other we have to balance both who's up who's down and are we closer distant and often women will walk away from a conversation asking did this bring us closer we'll push us farther apart where men are more likely to respond to the question,
而他做出的反应是针对这样的元信息：这是母亲对孩子说话的方式，或者是权力上位者对下属说话的方式。这指出了另一个经常出现在女性和男性之间的动态，当然，这种动态也可能出现在任何两个人之间。任何时候我们交谈，我们都必须平衡两件事：谁高谁低，以及我们是亲密还是疏远。通常，女性在谈话结束后会问：“这让我们更亲近了，还是把我们推得更远了？”而男性更有可能对另一个问题做出反应：
did this put one of us in a one-up or a one-down position? And there's so many examples of that, a woman who was hurt that her husband called up and said, I have a friend, my high school friend is in town, I'm gonna have dinner with him tonight. And she said, gee, you know, maybe I had some plants and why don't you ask how that's going to affect my plants?"
“这把我们中的一个置于优势地位还是劣势地位？”这样的例子太多了。有一个女人感到很受伤，因为她的电话打过来，说：“我有个朋友，我高中的朋友来这个城市了，我今晚要和他一起吃晚饭。”她说：“天哪，你知道的，也许我有一些植物，你为什么不问问这会怎么影响我的植物呢？”
And he said, I can't tell my friend I need to ask my wife for permission. Now it's checking with your wife, your spouse, the person you live with. Is this about permission? Who's up who's down? Or is it about connection? What we do affects each other. And so we negotiate things like that. So you write that the seeds of women's and men's style are sewn in the ways they learn to
他说：“我不能告诉我的朋友我需要请求我妻子的允许。”现在的问题是，跟你的妻子、你的配偶、与你生活在一起的人商量，这关乎允许吗？谁高谁低？还是关乎连接？我们的所作所为会影响彼此。所以我们会就这类事情进行协商。因此你写道，女性和男性沟通风格的种子是在他们学习
use language while growing up and that we grow up in different worlds, even when we grow up in the same household. What do you mean by that? Boys and girls tend to play in sex-separate groups. And the ways that they socialize, the way little girls and little boys use language and play tends to be different. Now, this is researched by psychologists, anthropologists, that have studied kids at play.
在成长过程中如何使用语言时埋下的，而且我们即使在同一个家庭中长大，也是在不同的世界里长大的。你这话是什么意思？男孩和女孩往往在按性别分开的群体中玩耍。他们社交的方式，小女孩和小男孩使用语言和玩耍的方式往往是不同的。现在，这是由研究儿童玩耍的心理学家和人类学家研究过的。
And they have observed that girls tend to play in smaller groups, often one-on-one, their social life often focused on a best friend. They spend a lot of time sitting and talking. Often it's telling secrets. I collect pictures from again all over the world. Two little girls, one is whispering in the other's ear. I have encountered a few pictures of boys doing that, but not many. Boys tend to play in larger groups, and it's the activity that's central. Your best friend is the one you do everything with.
他们观察到，女孩倾向于在较小的群体中玩耍，通常是一对一，她们的社交生活通常集中在最好的朋友身上。她们花大量时间坐在一起聊天。通常是讲秘密。我收集了来自世界各地的照片。两个小女孩，一个在另一个耳边低语。我遇到过一些男孩这样做的照片，但不多。男孩倾向于在较大的群体中玩耍，活动是核心。你最好的朋友就是和你一起做所有事情的那个人。
Marjorie Harnock's Goodman is an anthropologist at UCLA who has observed this. That boys will often tell the other boys what to do, and that gives them status in the group, the one who tells the other others what to do, and they listen, he's the leader. If girls tell other girls what to do, she's bossy and they don't want to play with her. And all of this, of course, has great implications for when your adults, especially in the world of work. The larger thing that I'm taking away from this is that all of us grow up in certain specific cultural worlds. And we're often those worlds I like, the water we swim in if we're fish.
加州大学洛杉矶分校的人类学家马乔里·哈诺克·古德曼观察到了这一点。男孩经常会告诉其他男孩该做什么，这在群体中赋予了他们地位，那个指挥其他人的人，而他们听从指挥，他就是领导者。如果女孩指挥其他女孩做什么，她就会被认为是专横的，她们就不想跟她玩了。当然，所有这一切对于你成年后、尤其是在职场中，都有着重大的意义。我从中体会到的更大的一点是，我们所有人都是在某些特定的文化世界中长大的。如果我们是鱼，这些世界就像我们游弋的水一样。
I mean, the worlds we don't even notice, we sort of assume that the entire world must be like the world in which we grow up. And we sort of naively assume that others share our cultural backgrounds and cultural worldviews. And so much miscommunication happens because of that. You've talked, for example, about how when people get married, they imagine that their partners are going to be, you know, better versions of all of the best friends they've had throughout the rest of their lives. And of course, that places significant burden
我的意思是，那些我们甚至没有注意到的世界，我们有点想当然地认为整个世界一定就像我们长大的那个世界一样。我们有点天真地认为别人也拥有与我们相同的文化背景和文化世界观。因此发生了大量的沟通不畅。比如，你曾谈到，当人们结婚时，他们会想象他们的伴侣会成为，你知道的，他们一生中所有最好朋友的升级版。当然，这给
on that new relationship. Yes, yes, I often say that for girls and women, talk is the glue that holds their relationship together and so they expect that when they if they're heterosexual and they Expect he's gonna be a new and improved version of a best friend He's gonna tell me everything and Then you get to the end of the day and he comes home and she tells him what happened and what she did and who she talked to and
这段新关系带来了沉重的负担。是的，是的，我经常说，对女孩和女人来说，谈话是维系她们关系的胶水，所以她们期望，如果她们是异性恋，并且她们期望他会是一个全新且改进版的最好朋友，他会把一切都告诉我，然后你到了了一天结束的时候，他回到家，她把发生了什么、她做了什么以及她和谁谈过话都告诉了他，而
what they said and what's that made her think and what that made her feel and then how was your day? Say, well, rap race. Really didn't anything happen? Nope. And then they go out to dinner and they're having dinner with a number of other couples and suddenly he's regaling the dinner party with something that happened during the day and she feels hurt. You know, what am I, top liver? Why didn't you tell me this? And it seems to really be a different sense of the place of talking a relationship. So for many, and guys and I always feel uncomfortable saying women men, when nothing is true of all
他们说过的话、这让她有什么想法、这让她有什么感受，然后问：“你今天过得怎么样？”回答说：“就那样。真的什么都没发生吗？”“没有。”然后他们出去吃晚饭，和好几对其他夫妇一起吃饭，突然间，他开始向晚宴上的众人讲述白天发生的一件事，而她却感到很受伤。你知道的，我是什么透明人吗？你为什么不告诉我这件事？这似乎确实反映出对谈话在一段关系中的地位有着完全不同的理解。所以对许多人而言——而且我在说“女人”和“男人”时总是感到很不自在，因为没有任何说法适用于所有
women and men, we have so many other influences on our style. But often men feel like just being together is what matters. So we can be not talking to each other and yet we're together and that's great. So it's a kind of public speaking and private speaking. From his point of view, when he's out with a group, he has to do his part, make know, make sure he gets the attention
女人和男人，我们的风格受到了太多其他因素的影响。但通常男人们会觉得，仅仅待在一起才是最重要的。所以我们可以不和对方说话，但我们在一起，这就很棒了。所以这是一种公共发言和私人发言。从他的角度来看，当他和一个群体外出时，他必须尽到自己的本分，你知道的，确保自己能获得应有的关注
and the respect that he deserves. And it's a kind of display. And here's when talk comes into its own. For many women, you know, when you're out, in public, you kind of have to be careful what you say. If you talk too much, people think you talk too much. You might say the wrong thing. You might offend somebody.
和尊重。这是一种展示。而这正是谈话大显身手的时候。对许多女性来说，你知道的，当你外出置身于公众场合时，你得小心自己说的话。如果你说得太多，人们就会觉得你说得太多。你可能会说错话。你可能会冒犯某人。
Now you're home with someone you're close to, you feel comfortable, you're free to talk. I'm wondering as you go through life, I mean, obviously you notice these things happening with other people, do you notice this happening in your own life, Deborah? Do you notice moments where you basically start and say, uh-oh, I understand, I miss the meta message of what was being communicated here.
现在你和亲近的人在家，你感到舒适，你可以畅所欲言。黛博拉，我想知道随着你的人生经历，我的意思是，很显然你注意到这些事情发生在其他人身上，你是否也注意到这些事情发生在你的生活中？黛博拉？你是否注意到这样一些时刻：你基本上刚一开口就说：“噢，我明白了，我错过了这里所传达的信息的潜台词。”
Well, I tell you one thing that comes to mind. This is before I was married, so it was the fellow I was dating at the time. And we were having an argument. The phone rang, somebody called and said, turn on the television, you're on the television right now. So we interrupt our argument, put on the television. And there I was being interviewed about conversational style. And what did you find out about conversation after listening to Walt?
嗯，我给你讲一件浮现在我脑海中的事。那是我结婚前的事，当时我和一个男生在约会。我们正在吵架。电话铃响了，有人打来电话说：“打开电视，你现在就在电视上。”于是我们中断了争吵，打开了电视。而屏幕上正播放着对我的采访，内容关于谈话风格。听了沃尔特的话后，你对谈话有了什么发现？
I was holding forth on something that was quite similar to what we were arguing about. So what's the answer in 10 seconds or less? Understand that there are conversational style differences. And sometimes the adversarial approach is not going to be the best one. And did he turn to you and say, Debra Tannen, could you listen to Debra Tannen? We just both laughed. It was so funny. Much of the time, misunderstandings don't end in laughter.
我当时正在长篇大论地谈论一些与我们争吵的内容相当相似的事情。那么，用十秒钟或更短的时间给出答案是什么？要明白人们的谈话风格是有差异的。有时，对抗性的方法并不是最佳方法。他有没有转向你并说：“黛博拉·坦宁，你能听听黛博拉·坦宁的话吗？”我们俩都笑了。太搞笑了。很多时候，误解并不以笑声结束。
They don't even end in outbursts of anger. Especially when it comes to friends or colleagues, we are hesitant to bring up misunderstandings. We let them go or we say we let them go, but they fester. Deborah recalls an incident like this. After she remarried, she and her husband had two friends over for dinner one night. A friend had come over and another friend of my husband's was there as well. And my friend, her name was Temera, Temera kept offering to help.
它们甚至不会以情绪的爆发而告终。特别是在面对朋友或同事时，我们往往羞于挑明误解。我们选择放下，或者我们嘴上说放下了，但它们却在心底溃烂。黛博拉回忆起过这样一件事。在她再婚后的一天晚上，她和丈夫邀请了两个朋友来家里吃晚饭。有个朋友过来了，我丈夫的另一个朋友也在场。我的朋友，她叫特梅拉，特梅拉一直主动提出要帮忙。
So when we were serving appetizers, she would help out by kind of offering people appetizers. And when it came to cleaning up, she was helping to clean up. And I kept telling her, no, you're the guest. You stay here. But she kept doing it anyway. And at one point, I was so frustrated,
所以在我们上开胃菜的时候，她会通过主动给人们递开胃菜来帮忙。到了清理的时候，她也在帮忙收拾。我一直告诉她：“不用，你是客。你坐着就好。”但她还是不停地帮忙。有一次，我实在是太沮丧了，
I actually grabbed her by the arm and popped her down. But she was up and trying to help watch the dishes. And I was so put off by it that I actually found myself thinking I'm not sure I wanted her to invite her again in life. Wait a minute. This is a good friend. I'm very fond of her. We can talk about it.
我甚至一把抓住她的胳膊把她按了下去。但她又站起来试图帮忙洗盘子。我对此感到非常反感，甚至发现自己在想，我以后都不确定还想不想再邀请她来了。等等。这是个好朋友。我非常喜欢她。我们可以开诚布公地谈谈。
And so we did. And she got this look of astonishment on her face and then, oh my God, she said, you know, I do that because that's how my mother doesn't, and that's how I've learned to do it. And she said, it just happened last night. My mother prepared dinner. I got up and I kept helping. And she said, don't do that.
于是我们真的谈了。她脸上露出了震惊的表情，然后说道：“哦天哪，你知道吗，我那样做是因为我妈就是这么做的，这也是我从小的习惯。”她说：“就在昨天刚发生过。我妈妈准备了晚餐。我站起来一直帮忙。”她说：“别这样。
Don't do that. You're the guest. Stay seated. And I cleared the table and I washed the dishes and I cleaned up. And when I was done, my mother said, thank you so much for doing that. And it was a revelation to both of us. There are many people for whom the assumption is,
别这样。你是客人。坐着别动。”于是我收拾了桌子，洗了盘子，打扫干净了。当我做完后，我妈妈说：“太谢谢你做这些了。”这给我们俩都上了一课。对许多人来说，他们心里的默认假设是：
I'm going to offer to help. You're going to tell me you don't want me to, but you really do want me to. in fact it was another friend. We were both guests somewhere and she did that and I said could you do me a favor ask the host the next day How she felt about that and she said the host sang her profusely She said I was so tired There was no way I could have watched all those dishes myself, I was so grateful.
“我要主动帮忙。你会告诉我你不需要，但你其实是希望我帮的。”事实上还有另一个朋友。我们俩当时都是某个地方的客人家宾客，她也这么做了，我对她说：“能帮个忙吗？第二天问问女主人她对此作何感想。”她说女主人对她千恩万谢。她说：“我太累了，我自己根本不可能洗完那些盘子，我太感激了。”
And I heard her saying, no, no, no, don't do it. Yeah, and the tricky thing that Deborah is, if you had asked that host, should I have helped, she may have well have told you no, you don't have to help, because she would have felt obliged to say that when in fact she did. I mean, so this is what makes it so tricky
而我听到她在说“不、不、不，别做了”。是的，黛博拉，棘手的地方就在于，如果你当时去问那位女主人“我应该帮忙吗？”，她很可能会告诉你“不用，你不需要帮忙”，因为她会觉得自己有义务这么说，而事实上她确实需要。我的意思是，这就是为什么这事如此棘手
that sometimes even doing the transparent thing of just asking the person tell me what your conversational style is. Even that does not elicit people's real conversational styles. You know you are so right. I was a guest at that dinner and I took the host at her word when she said she didn't want help I didn't help because that's how I prefer it. When I say I don't want help, I mean, and the term, again, this is from Gregory Bateson, meta-communicating, you talk about the communication. Metacommunicating often will work,
以至于有时哪怕采取开诚布公的做法，直接去问对方“告诉我你的谈话风格是什么”，甚至连这都无法引出人们真正的谈话风格。你知道吗，你说的太对了。我当时是那场晚宴的客人，当女主人说她不需要帮忙时，我把她的话当真了，我没有帮忙，因为我更喜欢这样。当我说我不需要帮忙时，我的意思是——而且这个词，再次引用格雷戈里·贝特森的话，叫“元传达”（meta-communicating），你在谈论沟通本身。元传达通常会起作用，
but often it doesn't, because people won't tell you. And I think of a classic example of that, someone suggests having lunch, and you don't really want to. You don't say, are you kidding? I would never have lunch with you. You say, oh, you know, today's I have a lot of words today. I don't think I'll do it today. So they ask you again. And then you say, oh, you know, I'm kind of don't feel that well today. And so finally, they say, are these excuses real? Or should I stop asking?
但往往它并不管用，因为人们不会对你吐露实情。我想到了一个经典的例子：有人建议一起吃午饭，而你其实并不想去。你不会说：“开什么玩笑？我绝不可能跟你吃午饭。”你会说：“哦，你知道吗，我今天有好多话要说。我觉得我今天去不了。”于是他们再次邀请你。接着你说：“哦，你知道的，我今天感觉有点不太舒服。”最后，他们会说：“这些借口都是真的吗？还是我应该别再问了？”
Because you really don't want to have lunch with me. Just still not going to say, no, I never want to have lunch with you. You're probably going to get even more indirect. Oh, no, no, I really mean it. You're right. It is extremely difficult. Unless you have the kind of relationship where you have agreed, we both know there is this thing called conversational style.
因为你真的不想跟我吃午饭。你依然不会说：“不，我永远不想跟你吃午饭。”你可能会变得更加含蓄。“噢，不，不，我真的是那个意思。”你说的对。这极其困难。除非你们建立了一种这样的关系：你们达成共识，我们都知道世上存在着所谓的“谈话风格”。
We both know these are things that can be tricky. So let's agree that we're going to be as upfront about it as we can when asked. The same as understandings in professional settings can result in managers feeling disrespected or ignored, and employees feeling bullied or confused. One of the managers that was studying told me, he said, you know, when I make a decision I just announce it and I assume that if people aren't happy with it they'll tell me, well that's going to work for some people and not for others. Right.
我们都知道这些事情可能会很棘手。所以我们同意，当被问到时，我们要尽可能坦诚地面对它。专业环境中的误解同样会导致管理者感到不被尊重或被忽视，而员工则会感到被霸凌或困惑。我研究过的一位经理曾对我说，他说：“你知道，当我做出决定时，我只是直接宣布，我以为如果大家对它不满意，会告诉我。”嗯，这可能对某些人管用，对其他人则不然。没错。
So, being aware of conversational style differences is something that applies in every conversation. Yeah. And you can see in the workplace a manager who tells a subordinate, you know, I'm wondering if you can do me a favor, can you get me an update on that report? In one situation, the employee can sort of say this person is not flaunting their power, even though they could just simply tell me to go and get the update on the report. They're actually opening a conversation that sort of makes me feel included, but somebody else could say, you know, why is the boss talking like he's a pushover? Why can't he just
因此，意识到谈话风格的差异适用于每一场对话。是的。你可以在职场中看到这样的情形：一个经理对下属说：“你知道的，我在想你能不 能帮我个忙，帮我弄一份那个报告的最新进展？”在某种情况下，员工可能会觉得这个人并没有在炫耀他们的权力，尽管他们完全可以直接命令我去拿报告的最新进展。他们其实是在开启一段对话，让我有一种被包容的感觉。但另一个人可能会说：“你知道吗，为什么老板说话的语气像个老好人？他为什么不能
simply tell me what he wants? And they're both perfectly legitimate ways of entering the conversation, but the ground rules need to be shared for the conversation to actually unfold successfully. I think power can be expressed in created either way. I was once told by a career naval officer. When he heard me talk about indirectness, he said, that's how the military works. I said, what? He said, when he was a midshipman just in training and one of the officers teaching in class came to the class
直接告诉我他想要什么呢？”这两种都是完全合情合理的切入对话的方式，但为了让对话真正顺利展开，双方需要有共同的基本准则。我认为无论采取哪种方式，权力都可以得到表达或构建。曾有一位职业海军军官对我说过。当他听到我谈论含蓄时，他说：“军队就是这样运作的。”我问：“什么？”他说，当他还是个刚在接受训练的见习军官时，课堂上一位授课军官来到教室
and he said, you know, it's cold in here and everybody nodded and he said, young men was men at the time. When I say something, I expect you to do something about it. So let's try that again. It's cold in here. And the officer was telling me this story said, and we all jumped up and went to close the windows, and that was a lesson we had learned that, serve just extremely well in the military, it was because of the power that he had the privilege of being indirect.
说道：“这里很冷。”每个人都点点头。他说：“年轻人”——当时都是指男性——“当我说话时，我期望你们采取行动。所以我们再试一次。这里很冷。”那个向我讲述这个故事的军官说：“我们立刻跳起来去关窗户。这是我们在军队里学到的一课，非常受用，正是因为他拥有那种特权，他才有特权表现得含蓄。”
being indirect. What makes all of this even more difficult is that the interplay of conversational styles changes from person to person. Debra, as a fast-talking New Yorker, learned she had to force herself not to jump in every time there was a pause in conversations she had with one colleague. I had to learn to count to seven before I thought he had nothing to say. His name was Ron Scullin, he was from the Midwest. He was married to Susie Scullin, who was Chinese from Hawaii. And when he talked to Susie, he was the one who kept interrupting.
表现得含蓄。这一切之所以更加困难，是因为谈话风格的相互作用因人而异。黛博拉作为一个语速极快的纽约人，她发现自己不得不强迫自己：在与一位同事交谈时，每当对话中出现停顿，她都不能立刻插话。“我必须学会数到七，才敢断定他真的无话可说。”他的名字叫罗恩·斯库林，来自中西部。他的妻子是苏茜·斯库林，是一名来自夏威夷的华裔。当他和苏茜交谈时，反而是那个不断打断别人的人。
And she would say, you ask me a question, and you don't give me time to answer. You're asking another one. He and Susie did research in Alaska among Athabaskin Indians. Susie was constantly interrupting the Athabaskins because their sense of pauses were longer than hers. So I like that example because it really drives home. We're not talking about absolutes. Yeah. You talk fast, you talk slow, it's always relative. When we come back, how to learn to code switch across the chasms of cross-cultural communication. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta.
而苏茜会说：“你问了我一个问题，却不给我时间回答。你紧接着又问了另一个。”他和苏茜曾在阿拉斯加的阿萨巴斯卡印第安人中做过研究。苏茜经常打断阿萨巴斯卡人，因为他们对停顿的时长感知比她更长。所以我喜欢这个例子，因为它真正深刻阐明了：我们讨论的不是绝对标准。是的。你语速快，你语速慢，这永远是相对的。稍后回来，我们将探讨如何学会在跨文化沟通的鸿沟之间进行“语码转换”。欢迎收听《隐藏大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
We've seen how different conversational styles can produce unintended conflict and misunderstanding. Linguist Deborah Tannen's more recent work has focused on the land mines buried in conversations between siblings, between parents and children, and between political adversaries. In all these realms, she finds that much animosity and conflict could be reduced if we only stop to do what her parents did during her childhood or what she did during her PhD dissertation. Step back from conversations and analyze them like a scientist. This is often very hard to do in real life because when people say
我们已经看到，不同的谈话风格如何引发意料之外的冲突与误解。语言学家黛博拉·坦宁近期的工作聚焦于埋藏在以下对话中的地雷：兄弟姐妹之间、父母与子女之间，以及政治对手之间。在所有这些领域中，她发现，如果我们能停下来去做她父母在她童年时做过的事，或者她做博士论文时做过的事，那么许多敌意和冲突本可以大大减少。从对话中抽离出来，像科学家一样去分析它们。这在现实生活中往往极其困难，因为当人们说出
things that upset us, we rarely stop to think. Deborah, after you started getting famous and went on TV all the time, your mom noticed something about your TV appearances. What was it? My mother was very upset that I was wearing the same red jacket on all the TV shows. She just complained. Of course, my mother was the only one who watched every show that I was on.
让我们心烦意乱的话时，我们很少会停下来思考。黛博拉，在你开始变得有名并频频上电视之后，你妈妈对你在电视上的露面注意到了一点。那是什么？我妈妈非常沮丧，因为我在所有的电视节目中都穿着同一件红夹克。她一直在抱怨。当然，我妈妈是唯一一个看遍了我参加过的所有节目的人。
At that time, it was every city you went to, you did a show, and so I had the jacket I was wearing on my book tour, but then she would watch them all back to back, and it really upset her. My mother always felt that I paid insufficient attention to my clothes. I have to mention one thing. Since your mom is not here to observe the
当时的情况是，你去到哪个城市就要做一个节目，所以我巡回宣传新书时一直穿着那件夹克。但她会把这些节目连着看好几集，这真的让她很不高兴。我妈妈总是觉得我对自己的衣服不够用心。我必须提一件事。既然你妈妈不在这里观察这场
conversation, I have to flag the fact that you are wearing a red jacket for this conversation today. No, it's just a red chittle neck, but I do like, I do like to wear red, it's true. And what was your reaction when your mom basically told you after you had finished this triumphant book tour, why are you wearing the same jacket all the time? What was your reaction, Deborah? I was, of course, heard that she was talking about what I was wearing and not what I said.
对话，我必须指出这样一个事实：你今天为了这场对话，穿了一件红夹克。不，这只是一件红色的高领衫，但我确实喜欢，我确实喜欢穿红色，这是真的。当你妈妈在你完成了一次凯旋般的新书巡回宣传后，对你说“你为什么总是穿着同一件夹克”时，你的反应是什么，黛博拉？我当然感到受伤，因为她在意的是我穿什么，而不是我说了什么。
And I remember discussing this with the host on one of the national morning shows. She told me that her mother did that, that her mother would tell her after each morning what was wrong with what she was wearing, or maybe what was wrong with her hair. The kind of interaction Deborah had with her mother has long been a staple of television comedy.
我记得我和某档全国早间节目的主持人讨论过这件事。她告诉我，她的妈妈也会这样，她的妈妈会在每天早上节目结束后指出她穿的衣服哪里不对，或者可能是她的头发哪里不对。黛博拉与她母亲之间的这种互动长期以来一直是电视喜剧的核心素材。
In Vipe, Julia Louis Dreyfus plays a politician and a mom. In one episode, her daughter reaches out where the heart felt plea. I have had a hard, lonely, miserable life, and the only thing that is going to make it worthwhile is if I become the daughter of the next president of the United States. Okay, sweetie, thanks. And that jacket doesn't work. By the way, you look like a waiter. Oh, God, damn it. Deborah writes about what she calls the big three flashpoints in conflicts between mothers and daughters. Hair, clothes, and weight. And the mother-daughter relationship in some ways
在《副总统》中，朱莉·路易斯-德赖弗斯饰演一位政客兼母亲。在其中一集里，她的女儿带着诚挚的恳求走上前去。“我过着艰难、孤独、悲惨的生活，唯一能让这一切变得有意义的事，就是我成为美国下一任总统的女儿。”“好吧，甜心，谢谢。还有，那件夹克不搭。顺便说一句，你看上去像个服务员。”“哦，该死。”黛博拉写到了她所说的母女冲突中的三大雷区：发型、服装和体重。某种程度上，母女关系
is a perfect storm. From the point of view of the daughter, here's the person you most want to think you're perfect. You think she knows you so well and if she thinks you're wanting, then you really must be fatally flawed. From the point of view of the mother, here's the person you most want to help to make sure everything goes as well as it could for her. And women are judged by appearance, hair and clothes and weight. So from the point of view of the mother, this is caring. I just want to make sure everything goes well for you. Nobody else will tell you because they don't love you as much as I do. They don't care as much as I do. But
是一场完美的风暴。从女儿的角度来看，眼前这个人是你最希望认为你是完美的人。你觉得她对你极度了解，如果她觉得你有所欠缺，那你一定存在致命的缺陷。从母亲的角度来看，眼前这个人是你最想帮助的人，你要确保她的一切都尽可能顺利。而女性往往会因外表、发型、服装和体重而受到评判。所以从母亲的角度来看，这是出于关心。我只是想确保你一切顺利。别人不会告诉你，因为他们没有我这么爱你。他们没有我这么在乎你。但是
anytime you make a suggestion for improvement, you are implying criticism. And that's what the daughters hear. So in fact, my mother's critical is one of the biggest complaints I heard from adult daughters and one of the biggest complaints I heard from mothers of adult daughters was, I can't open my mouth. She takes everything as criticism. And it's both. It's not who's right, who's wrong. It's that suggestions for improvement really are implied criticism and are also a sign of caring.
每当你提出改进的建议时，你就是在暗示批评。而这正是女儿们所听到的。事实上，我妈妈的批评是我从成年女儿那里听到最多的抱怨之一，也是成年女儿的母亲们向我抱怨最多的一点：“我根本没办法开口。她把任何事都当成批评。”其实这两者兼而有之。这不是谁对谁错的问题。改进的建议确实既暗示了批评，同时也表达了关心。
I understand that one time your mom asked you about your hair? and are also a sign of caring. I understand that one time your mom asked you about your hair. Yes. Tell me about that. I was visiting my mother and she said, do you like your hair that long? And I burst out laughing and she asked why. And I said, well, you know, I'm writing this book about mothers and daughters and so many daughters tell me their mothers are critical of their hair. And she said, well, you know, I'm writing this book about mothers and daughters and so many daughters tell me their mothers are critical of their hair.
我听说有一次你妈妈问起你的头发？同时也表达了关心。我听说有一次你妈妈问起你的头发。是的。跟我讲讲那次经历。我当时正在看望我母亲，她问：“你喜欢把头发留这么长吗？”我忍不住哈哈大笑，她问我为什么笑。我说：“嗯，你知道的，我正在写一本关于母女关系的书，很多女儿都告诉我，她们的母亲对她们的发型百般挑剔。”而她说：
And she said, I wasn't criticizing. So I let it drop. And then later in the visit, I said, so mom, what do you think of my hair? And she said, I think it's a little too long. Now, I was one of this one woman who said to me, she was in her 60s and so her mother would have been in her 80s and she said, my mother's losing her eyesight. But she can still spot a pimple across the room. Now, that was said in the spirit of my mother's going to find my flaw, the one thing, the one flaw. Now, who, when they look at you, is going to see the pimple yourself. Right. And mothers and daughters often look at each other
“我可不是在挑剔。”所以我没再继续这个话题。后来在探望期间我又说：“妈，那你觉得我的头发怎么样？”她说：“我觉得稍微有点长。”当时有一个女人对我说，她已经60多岁了，所以她母亲应该80多岁了，她说：“我母亲视力正在衰退。但她依然能在房间的另一头一眼挑出一颗青春痘。”这话的意思是，我母亲一定会找出我的瑕疵，那唯的一一个瑕疵。那么，当别人看着你时，谁会一眼看到你身上的瑕疵呢？没错。母亲和女儿经常把彼此看作
as reflections of themselves, and therefore, with the same level of scrutiny, to which they subject themselves. Hmm. And we touched on this earlier in our conversation. All of these categories are going to be influenced by class, by culture, by nationality in all kinds of interesting ways. They might be cultures where moms are expressing their concerns in terms of how their daughters
作为他们自己的反映，因此，他们会以对待自己的那种严苛程度来进行审视。嗯。我们在先前的对话中也谈到过这一点。所有这些类别都会受到阶层、文化、国籍等各种有趣方式的影响。有些文化中，妈妈们可能会通过表达她们的女儿
are not eating enough, not that they're eating too much. I mean, so a lot of this is culturally specific. Not necessarily that all mothers and all daughters in all cultures behave exactly the same way. Yeah, well, the specifics may be different. And by the way, I have been told by some women, my mother never did that, my mother never criticized. So all these things are not everybody, not 100%. But the pattern seemed to be pretty cross-cultural. So, for example, a woman from Oman told me that mother's there might say to their daughters,
没有吃饱，而不是吃得太多，来表达她们的担忧。所以，很大程度上这是具有文化特异性的。并不一定所有文化中的所有母亲和所有女儿都表现得完全一样。是的，好吧，具体细节可能会有所不同。顺便说一句，一些女性曾对我说，我妈妈从来不那样做，我妈妈从未批评过我。所以所有这些事情并不适用于所有人，并非百分之百。但这种模式似乎具有相当强的跨文化性。所以，例如，来自阿曼的一位女性告诉我，那里的母亲可能会对她们的女儿说：
I can see hair, meaning your hijab isn't completely covering your hair. Or a woman told me, this is from Africa, she had a wedding, she was going to go to, she showed her mother the dress she was planning to wear for the wedding. The mother made a comment that she didn't think it was appropriate. And so the daughter stayed up the whole night sewing a new dress for the wedding. Wow. So the specifics may be different, but the mother being the guardian of the daughter's appearance, because women are judged by appearance.
“我看到头发了”，意思是你的头巾没有完全遮住头发。或者一个女性告诉我，这是来自非洲的，她有一场婚礼要参加，她把她打算在婚礼上穿的裙子拿给母亲看。母亲评论说她认为这不合适。于是女儿整晚没睡，为婚礼缝制了一件新裙子。哇。所以具体细节可能有所不同，但母亲是女儿外表的守护者，因为女性是以其外表来评判的。
As I read your work, Debra, I was struck by how naively many of us enter conversations. You know, we think conversations are like a walk in the park. When really it's often potentially a walk across a minefield. And the fact that we're naive about the challenges is actually one of the dangers. We, this is why we never expected when things blow up in our faces. Yes, and this is partly why it's so satisfying when it goes well.
黛比，当我读你的作品时，我被我们许多人以多么天真的态度进入对话所震撼。你知道的，我们认为对话就像在公园里散步。而实际上，它往往潜在地就像走过一片雷区。我们对这些挑战的天真态度，实际上正是危险之一。这就是为什么当事情在我们面前搞砸时，我们从不曾料到。是的，这也是为什么当对话进展顺利时会如此令人满足的部分原因。
There are so many things that could misfire the pace at which you speak, not just how long you wait between turns, but how quickly, within turns, how you get to the point. Do you get right to the point or do you start kind of vague so that if you're talking to someone who doesn't work that way, they cut you off before you get to the point because they think you've had a chance. The rhythms, the music of speech, the intonation patterns, humor, that is a minefield. What can you tell jokes about?
有太多事情可能会出错：你说话的节奏，不仅仅是你等待轮到自己发言的时间有多长，还有在发言期间你的语速，你是如何切入正题的。你是直奔主题，还是开始时有点含糊其辞，结果如果你在跟一个不那样做事的人说话时，他们在你切入正题之前就把你打断了，因为他们认为你已经有过机会了。节奏，言语的音乐，语调模式，幽默，那可是一片雷区。你可以拿什么开玩笑？
How do you let people know that you're joking and that you're teasing? I'm wondering, Deborah, if one of the solutions that might be called for is in some ways for all of us to exercise both a little more empathy but also a little more compassion for one another. In other words, to start with the assumption that misunderstandings are happening because of unintended signals. In other words, to extend to the other people in our lives, whether those are work colleagues or people in our personal lives, that if a misunderstanding
你如何让人们知道你在开玩笑、你在逗他们？黛比，我在想，可能需要的一种解决方案在某种程度上是我们所有人都要多一点同理心，同时也彼此多一点慈悲。换句话说，从这样的假设开始：误解的发生是因为无意的信号。换句话说，向我们生活中的其他人，无论是同事还是我们个人生活中的人传递这样一点：如果误解
has occurred, odds are it's probably happened because of a miscommunication, not because someone intended to hurt us. That's a great way to look at it. I often say mine is a rhetoric of good intentions. And people sometimes object to my work, they say, well, what if people don't mean well? What if they really are out to get you? What if they really are hostile?
已经发生，大概率是因为沟通不畅，而不是因为有人故意伤害我们。这是一个很好的看待问题的方式。我经常说我的是一种善意修辞。人们有时会反驳我的作品，他们会说，好吧，如果人们并没有善意呢？如果他们真的是冲着你来的呢？如果他们真的充满敌意呢？
And my response is, that's not news. People are always ready to see other people that's having bad intentions and being up to no good or having bad personality characteristics. So the news that my work can provide is to step back and think what if they don't have bad intentions but have different conversational style, different ways of trying to accomplish the positive things they're trying to accomplish. And what's thinking about conversational style does is give you a way to imagine different
我的回应是，这并非新闻。人们总是准备好看到其他人怀有恶意、图谋不轨或者有着糟糕的性格特征。所以我的作品所能提供的新闻是退后一步，想想如果他们没有恶意，而是有不同的对话风格、有不同的方式来试图达成他们想要达到的积极成果会怎样。思考对话风格所能做的是为你提供一种想象不同
intentions. Yeah. We had the actor and writer Alan Alda on Hidden Brain a couple of years ago and he said something that was very insightful. It's possible, of course, that if we imagine that other people are not trying to harm us, we could be wrong. In fact, they might actually be out to get us and we could be naive about it. But he said, the more empathy I have for other people, the less annoying I find that they are. And you know, it's a separate from the fact that whatever people's real intentions might be, it might actually be just be better
意图的方法。是的。几年前，演员兼作家阿兰·阿尔达做客我们的“隐藏大脑”节目时，他说过一番非常深刻的话。当然，如果我们想象其他人不是在试图伤害我们，我们有可能是错的。事实上，他们可能真的是在针对我们，而我们可能对此很天真。但他说，我对其他人抱有的同理心越多，我发现他们烦人的程度就越低。你知道的，抛开不管人们真实的意图可能是什么，展现
for us to show my empathy because we'll end up being less triggered by other people. I love that perspective, absolutely. If you frame everything as a fight, it's corrosive to the human spirit. Everyone feels less safe and more vulnerable. If you get in the habit of seeing good intentions, yeah, maybe you'll miss a few bad intentions and think better of a few people that don't deserve it. But the world will feel like a safer place,
同理心对我们来说可能实际上更好，因为我们最终会被其他人触发的程度会降低。我非常喜欢这个视角，绝对如此。如果你把每件事都框定为一场争斗，这对人类精神具有腐蚀性。每个人都感觉更不安全，更脆弱。如果你养成了看到善意的习惯，是的，也许你会错过一些恶意，并对几个不值得的人做出过高的评价。但这个世界会感觉像是一个更安全的地方，
whether you're right or not. But I think you'll be right more often than you realize. Debra Tannen is a linguist at Georgetown University. Her books include, That's Not What I meant. You just don't understand women and men in conversation, and you're wearing that, understanding mothers and daughters in conversation. Her most recent book is Finding My Father. Debra, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you, it's really been a pleasure. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Laura Quarelle, Kristen Wong, Ryan Katz,
不管你是对是错。但我认为你会比你意识到的更多时候是正确的。黛比·坦嫩是乔治敦大学的语言学家。她的著作包括《那不是我的意思：你就是不懂在对话中的女人和男人》以及《你穿着那样的衣服吗：理解母女对话》。她最近的一本著作是《寻找我的父亲》。黛比，谢谢你今天做客“隐藏大脑”。谢谢，这真的是一种荣幸。“隐藏大脑”由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、劳拉·夸雷勒、克里斯汀·王、瑞安·卡茨、
Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our Ronsang here today is Ben Riskin. Ben is a co-founder of Room Tone, a consulting firm that provides strategic and managerial support to podcasters. Ben is someone who seems to know everyone in the audio field and even better he enjoys making connections between people who have shared interests. Since we launched our independent production company last
奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德里克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是“隐藏大脑”的执行主编。我们今天的嘉宾是本·里斯金。本是 Room Tone 的联合创始人，这是一家为播客提供战略和管理支持的咨询公司。本似乎是那种在音频领域认识所有人的人，更好的是，他喜欢在有共同兴趣的人之间建立联系。自从我们独立的制作公司于去年
fall we have greatly enjoyed chatting with Ben and hearing his insights on where the podcasting industry is headed. Thank you Ben. For more hidden brain, be sure to subscribe to our newsletter. You can sign up at news.hiddenbrain.org. If you liked this episode and you'd like to support our work, please go to hiddenbrain.org and click on support. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you next week.
秋季创立以来，我们非常高兴能与本聊天，并倾听他对播客行业发展方向的见解。谢谢你，本。有关“隐藏大脑”的更多内容，请务必订阅我们的简报。您可以在 news.hiddenbrain.org 注册。如果您喜欢这一集并希望支持我们的工作，请访问 hiddenbrain.org 并点击“支持”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。下周见。
you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你 本集节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。